it's the blood composition that controls  the genes well then who or what controls  the chemistry of the blood i go the  brain whatever picture you have in your  mind the brain will translate that into  complementary chemistry and then release  it in the blood and then your cells will  conform to the picture in your mind if i  have a picture of love in my mind i  release wonderful chemistry into the  blood dopamine pleasure that's why you  always fall in love it feels so good and  most importantly when you're in love you  release what is called growth hormone  people in love glow they're healthy  they're vital they're vibrant fear  causes stress chemistry stress chemistry  shuts down growth less than one percent  of diseases even connected to genes  you can come with a normal gene but with  a picture that's skewed you can alter  the readout of the gene and make cancer  90 percent of cancer is not even  genetically connected in the family